based on the toy franchise with no story
or defined characters comes a
feature-length commercial full of
celebrities cliches and repetitive pop
music that's really sweet and heartfelt
huh didn't see that coming the lego
movie enter a world of unlimited lego
playsets where characters from Star Wars
DC Harry Potter Lord of the Rings and
Cosette all join together to save the
world but instead we're stuck with this
guy
meet Emmet a clueless suck-up who lives
in a city full of mindless drones
complete with its own version of Two and
a Half Men watch him convince the world
to follow instructions work together and
sacrifice their personal goals for the
greater good of stopping the evil
president business
wait is this when we gonna turn my kid
into a communist laughs along at the mix
of experts CGI and comically bad live
action that covers up the horrific
reality of what you're actually watching
like this cop killing his own parents
the destruction of an entire city full
of people
the brew will be heading of one of the
film's heroes and the fact that this
father and son have created a sentient
universe in their basement that they can
destroy at any time and don't tell me in
the comments that it's just make-believe
because that Lego dude totally moves on
his own so strap in for this
crowd-pleaser that didn't even crack the
Academy's top 5 animated Bills losing
out to things no one saw like song of
the sea' and the tale of the tiny and
princess but was so successful and
beloved your kids still can't stop
singing the movies hit song so get ready
because we're about to get this one
stuck in your head again
get more icy patches
our broader Lego Batman that's our raw
data Batman movie haha chronic
everything's better we're licensed
intellectual property shiny
we
starry trash Chomper bad cop car chase
of flying flusher bad cops pursued super
secret police dropship Benny spaceship
spaceship spaceship super cycle chains
Castle cavalry rescue reinforcements
loud cuckoo Powles so piece of
resistance and M its constructor Mac
also starring metal beard seek ow metal
beards dual creative ambush
double-decker couch melting room getaway
glider ward businesses evil lair
ice-cream machine and where are my pants
guy minifigure the lego commercial
then kind of feel like buying some Legos
right now how about you guys yeah yeah
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers thanks to our friends at epic
Rap Battles of History for lending us
their awesome rhymes check out their
channel at the link below and tell them
screen junkies at you Morgan Freeman
wishes his voice was as sexy as mine I
like squishy stuff I'm just here so I
don't get fined tonight we hunt boom
boom chubby June June family duty honor
they call me Dragan Stein